so was geht hier ist ein marx und
herzlich willkommen zur nächsten folge
minecraft nero ich nehme die direkt im
anschluss an die letzte folge auf weil
ich unbedingt jetzt den blue devils 2
fertig machen möchte und ich schreib
doch mal nutzer hey hey so alle leute
begrüßt und wir checken dass man weiter
aus dass wir auch es liegt jetzt aber
doch bitte nicht ich habe eigentlich in
der zwischenzeit nur noch ein bisschen
speicher frei geschafft also legen
sollte oder hilft es eigentlich nicht
das wäre nicht wirklich logisch wenn es
jetzt legt aber für die sache die ich
jetzt vor habe erstmal sind längst nicht
so schlimm sage ich mein blut zack zack
zack sowie kommen definitiv dem ziel
näher
da muss man aufpassen dass ich den ich
mal irgendwann verliere den blut obwohl
wenn er so ständig rausfällt ich habe
hier nur weil er halt frame drops des
todes das ein bisschen ärgerlich so zwei
stück brauche ich noch mehr nicht dann
haben wir den altar der 2
da müssen wir noch eine ganze menge blut
spenden
ich kann auch mal platt auf eingeben
dafür brauchte ich auch den embedded
plattform der brandort 5000 lp also
quasi fünfmal so lange wie es mit so
einem blank slate dauert das bedeutet
aber wiederum dass wir auf jeden fall
trotzdem noch zeit haben werden den es
heute noch mein angriff zu nehmen und
uns die verdammte festung vorzuknöpfen
ich habe ja immer noch mal mein blatt
backe ich weiß nicht ob das verzicht
wenn ich das jetzt hier einsätze deshalb
lasse ich da lieber mal komplett die
finger von das irgendwie einzusetzen
kann ich die allen bars irgendwie oben
verwenden glaube nicht okay ich glaube
ich ich mit dem dach beschäftige ich
mich erst weil es dauert ja solange
hochzuklettern beschäftige ich mich erst
wenn der links drinliegt
der emerald weil er wie gesagt eine
ganze menge braucht so ich weiß jetzt
allerdings nicht ob wenn ich das zeug
abbauen
das ganze ja das ganze weg ist wisst ihr
ich meine ob dann das ganze blut was
sich derzeit da drin befindet das sind
ja wie viele lebenspunkte 2270 wobei das
ist jetzt nicht so unendlich viel was da
gerade drin ist ob das dann verschwindet
wenn ich den abbau weil ich musste ja
nach oben dorthin platzieren
später muss ich dann noch eine
konstruktion mit glos ton und noch eine
ganze menge weiteren ruhen machen aber
erst mal ist das glaube ich echt gut
blatt letters pack es gibt ja eigentlich
für interessante sachen wie man blut ein
geplatzter source plattform ist wo platz
ist an all 18 damage ich vermute mal das
gibt es im netz
da halte ich auf jeden fall gleich
einmal die augen nach auf weil das
natürlich der wahnsinn wir noch mal
irgendwie so richtig krank das schwert
kriegen wobei dass da viel zeit hat ja
auch 17 es macht jetzt keinen
gigantischen unterschied aber wieviel
users hat das ding hier
1804 also es dürfte auch so um den dreh
oder 2500 tatsächlich also ist sogar ja
doch noch mal ein wenig besser da müssen
wir noch ein bisschen essen holen gehen
irgendwas essens mesz am start eine farm
oder so es wäre natürlich optimal wenn
komme irgendwie schon so eine farm am
start hätte so und da ist jetzt das
letzte play slate was wir erstmal
produzieren müssen
zack zack zack
auch stressig ich brauch noch 22
queenston okay die kann ich ganz ganz
schnell machen
her damit klinsmann braucht es auf jeden
fall jede menge das smartpad hier
da muss ihr euch schon mal vor waren
falls ihr queenston hast dann müsst ihr
leider jetzt abschalten ein schwarzes
kleid und her damit
jetzt haben wir es eigentlich alles klar
kommen was mache ich hier eigentlich
kräfte so ein ich kräfte richtig
eigentümlich verliebtsein drüber damit
so jetzt haben wir die letzten beiden
blatt booms ab nach oben
die letzten beiden blatt wir uns
platziert jetzt vor den altar so her
damit
der ist abgebaut und den platzieren wir
es da oben hin und damit haben wir dem
blatt alter level 2 erreicht und das
ganze schöne blut was drin war ist
leider buchstäblich verpufft in dem wir
gerade abgebaut haben ich habe ich
glaube ich habe wie viele sind es noch
mal 4000 lebenspunkte opfert man wenn
man sich komplett 2000 lebenspunkte
erfährt man wenn man sich komplett
opfert in dieses teil
und das heißt ich muss mich für 5000
dementsprechend matheaufgabe ich muss
nie wieder machen ich habe ja wobei ich
habe es noch nicht ich hoffe mal dass
ich habe ich muss auf jeden fall häufig
opfern
aber das ist ganz gut weil so kann ich
einfach nebenbei kann stelle ich hier
rom bauen ist natürlich auch so
riskanten ich meine ich fall hier einmal
runter und ich bin tot aber ich habe
auch kein essen werde nur noch ein
bisschen song break damit muss ich dann
aber auch wirklich noch mal vor zu den
melonen gehen und ein paar werde ich
auch an pflanzen nicht dass wieder
beschwerden gibt weil nutzer weil ja
selbstverständlich dass die einfach
nicht komplett aufgegessen werden
ich hatte fast am anfang gehofft dass es
ein bisschen länger hält mal essen was
ich mir am anfang stibitzt haben so
gehwegen nach oben können wieder opfern
o.ä
wir gehen ist jetzt weg es geht ja viel
schneller als ich es auch fahren kann
das blut wie denn dann habe ich kann
hier überhaupt nicht ein
oh mann
ok ich halt mal skype offen komme ist
mal wieder gestorben
überrascht eigentlich noch
irgendjemanden hier wie auch verdammt
commander of the game
ich frag mal wo vielleicht kann ich
nämlich retten
ich glaube da muss ich doch noch eine
andere taktik verfolgen damit ich das
noch machen kann weil ich werde einfach
den alltag voll machen müssen
mit meinem ganzen blut und dann löcher
oder wie ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
man keinen solchen effekt bekommt heftig
so noch mal blutspenden vertritt wie
sohn peter müsste mal auf dem folge 12
woher stimmt peter gerade was sinnvolles
angemerkt in der konfi
ok so das brauche ich einfach mal ab
jetzt gehe ich einfach mal fristlos weil
essen muss jetzt einfach essen muss
jetzt ran
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich sterbe
falls ich von irgendwas eingegriffen
werde
ist leider etwas hoch aber darüber
denken wir jetzt einfach mal nicht
weiter nach sondern suchen das schiff da
vorne auf sieben minuten 50 haben wir
mal ich verliere so extrem schwer ist
ich hoffe mal dass jetzt noch ein
bisschen melonen dort sind weil sonst ja
ist bei mir irgendwie auch vorbei habe
ich erst mal alle geholt
nein nicht alle anschein hat jemand
anderes alle geholt
verdammt ich wollte wieder welche
anbauen wo gibt's hier unten irgendwas
was zu holen
nee leute ich komme bei patrick zu hause
weil er es ja sowieso aktuell nicht in
nicht in der stadt aber so vor
so legt mir gehörig steine in den weg
jetzt kein essen zu haben ich habe auch
geschrieben dass er mir sagen kann wo
jetzt sowas steht witzig mehr vermeint
weiß nicht von wem das ist aber song the
brains hoffe er wird mir nicht sehr
sauer dumm sein derjenige dem das hier
gehört
soweit ich muss mir orientieren wo ist
patrick noch mal
er tritt hier vor allem warum springt
dich auch noch auch leute da hat man
einmal eine proaktive folge und denkt
sich dass rom ist mit den mit den
nervigen mit den nervigen
angelegenheiten und dann gibt's schon
die nächsten probleme
das ist nur eine lampe gläubiger wird
den bedarf komplett aus kriegen wer
sonst ziemlich nice hier gibt es leider
kein essen eine feder vielleicht im
vertrieb noch verdammt
die facc jetzt muss ich einfach muss
jetzt monster jagen gehen
das ist stressig kann man die farben
anlegen
unten an meinem haus nicht habe ich ein
bisschen bauen mir in meinen kisten oder
patrick weiß mich in der regel beweise
sachen wie knochen eigentlich gar nicht
auf
einfach weil ich nie survival spiele so
kommen wir wollen noch ein bisschen was
das jetzt ein buchstäblich survival weil
wenn ich nichts esse sterbe ich ja
sowohl auf das dumme ist
ich bin irgendwie ziemlich dumm so hier
nochmal rein patrick baum ihr knochen
nein leider nicht
oh mann oh mann
wir sind richtige chaoten stadt habe ich
gefühl komisch die ganze zeit patrick
des unterwegs ich kriege es irgendwen
ich hin
vernünftig zu leben einfach irgendwas
essens mäßiges drin wird wahrscheinlich
nichts drin sein
mehr das tun was kaputt gemacht habe so
stressig sehr sehr stressig und ich
neige mich wirklich dem dem ende meiner
hunger weiter zu ich finde da sieht
schon wieder ganz lustig aus meinem ein
kleines päuschen hier so robert bitte
habe ich jetzt in der kiste ein paar
knochen nicht einen
auch verdammt wir wohnten hier drüben
ich will niemandem essen klar
dem waren dem ich nicht mehr weiß wer es
ist wird das nil oder thema der stege
aber ich muss ja was essen
ich guck mal da rein vielleicht gibt es
auch irgendwelche schied nur die ich mir
klauen kann aber ich mache mir hier in
wassereimer sie können so 123 dann
pflanze ich mir zumindest mal unten
unter meinem haus ein bisschen weizen an
wie komme ich jetzt herunter ohne fall
schaden zu bekommen und dann
wahrscheinlich noch daran zu sterben so
am besten ist oder einfach durch haus
aber auf die tier kann ich natürlich
nicht erst klar wo ist mein haus da bist
du da bist du da mache sie drunter aber
direkten feld fabian damit und zack zack
leute das ist wirklich richtig arm was
ich hier gerade mache das ist so
selbst versorgers da hätte ich glaube
ich suche jetzt wirklich mal da drüben
die bude auf und ich dachte es würde
irgendwie würde so gehen wie es mir
vorgestellt habe
also dass ich im alltag den den embedded
rein machen und dann immer wieder mal
blut tropfte wenn ich neu generiert habe
aber anscheinend ist es nicht so
vorgesehen
der verbrauch das zeug schneller als man
es wieder rein spenden kann also
eigentlich nicht durch eigentliches nice
wenn es ein bisschen flotter verbraucht
sie ist auch nicht von der person den
berg zerstören
herberg wann konnte ich so ein paar
verlässt der staatlichen lustig oder
sagen wir so bitte essen
1633 robbie ich will hier jetzt nicht
ich will jetzt nicht klauen aber okay
bei uns hoffentlich brauche diese person
einfach keine knochen
oh je falls doch dann geht ruhig zu ihr
und pads ich hatte wenig gerade
bescheuert irgendwie sekunde
halos hier ist bei 352 135 135 23 52
handy das passt doch eigentlich kann ja
einmal sagen was hier abgeht
ich brauche ein bisschen essen um an zu
eine echt leid denjenigen denen ich dass
er gerade klar dass essen
aber wie macht man eine folge sonst
kaputt ich bei uns bei uns allen eine
farm die ihr könnt euch alle bedienen
ich werde es auf jeden fall nicht so
dumm sein und das zeug essen
oh mann ich fühle mich schlecht weil ich
das hier gerade klar kommt wie
unvorsichtig binden so ist das normales
gras spieler normalerweise nie mit dem
sex gras texturen
aber ich glaube dass normales glas
ach mensch ok ich kann auf jeden fall
die nächste folge aufnehmen bevor ich
nicht irgendwie eine lösung für die wird
das essen das problem habe weil so lässt
sich nicht vernünftig eine folge
aufnehmen oder ich muss einfach essen
jagen gehen
es wäre natürlich auch eine möglichkeit
aber stressig das nächste probleme
einfach wieder denkt man einmal man hat
irgendwie etwas geschafft hat irgendwas
geregelt und dann zwei stakes kann ich
mir jetzt also braten
ihr dürft ihr aber einmal vor
regenerieren können denke ich so rein
damit oma habe ich nicht nachgedacht
irgendwie ich kenne das aus dem projekt
nicht dass mir das essen ausgeht
die gehen auch mal diese ganzen kuchen
aber dafür braucht man immer entweder
das oder kakao oder japans sind glaube
ich es nicht direkt hier um die ecke
ansonsten könnte ich mir natürlich
pumpkin pie machen ich glaube als ob das
jetzt voll der zufall weil er habe ich
ja zumindest drei stück und wird es
regeneriert die auch ein bisschen essen
habe ich mir schon jemals in minecraft
auch nur ein paar kind paul gemacht
welches überlege ich glaube ich habe das
noch nie gemacht in meinem ganzen
minecraft leben wie noch nie auch nur
ein pumpkin pie gegessen und ich sprinte
natürlich leute weil hier so viel hunger
balken habe mir das locker erlauben kann
so verdammt per 1 die regeneriert hier
glaube ich die meisten lebenspunkte also
das kann jetzt wirklich nur glück nennen
dass wir dieses ding wirklich fußläufig
von meinem haus hatten mehr braucht hier
gar nicht habe nur drei eier wenn ihr
versteht was ich meine
wer schon mehr als die meisten haben
aber dumme witze und dann will ich das
irgendwie cool darstellen dass ich so
witze machen aber es ist halt nicht cool
ob das wohl komme ist ganz grabstein
platzieren vielleicht einfach mal auf
dem friedhof sicherheitshalber aber
vielleicht ist es ja wirklich gomez und
ich habe ihn gerade damit wiederbelebt
natürlich ein ziemlicher zu fall aber
der ist ja am falschen gestorben wie
soll man dort irgendwie an falsch
artensterben bisher nicht irgendwie in
der luft oder so aber andererseits ist
das komma ecke mister ich sterbe jede
folge ok ich natürlich mit den witzen
aufhören sonst denken leute noch dass
ich komme dass ich komme irgendwie was
böses möchte natürlich nicht der fall
findet ein super kerl zack und es wächst
auch schon das erste bisschen gucken ob
dieser pilz muss auf den fersen ist und
ich weiß natürlich dass einzig
vernünftige machen wenn ich endlich mal
wieder volle generiert werden und mein
ganzes blut hier rein rotzen gibt es
widersprüche irgend jemand der sagt dass
es unvernünftig ist näher oder so ist
klar das sind hier echte survival tipps
was macht man sich ja wirklich nicht
häufig was mir gerade zu essen
präparieren
aber
ich habe letzte folge die an die wand
geworfen
wieso darf ich eigentlich existieren
können wir erst mal irgendjemand sagen
ohne spaß
ich darf doch gar nicht leben so tom
hicks bin wo man wie viel ist jetzt drin
wir sind schon bei 18 minuten 1400 nur
alters current essens 3800 es könnte
klappen
es könnte noch klappen dass wir das
hinbekommen
also das ist zumindest beim nächsten
einloggen fertig ist der nächste blatt
ob ich gebe auf jeden fall den links
platzieren den grabstein einfach in der
annahme dass der von gome ist es wäre
natürlich jetzt echt mega heiß wenn ich
komme dadurch wieder retten könnte aber
ich glaube die grabsteine sind
eigentlich immer so normale grabsteine
ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie so ein
random spawn ansonsten einfach mal hin
damit und hoffen dass das komme war
alles klar machen
war das essen geht weg wie noch was
wahrscheinlich welche sprinter wieder an
ein genauer bei patrick gucken
die folge nährt sich auch schon wieder
dem ende mann
der server überraschungseier
der ist übrigens von mir ne quatsch die
bücher sind von mir kräftig konnte sich
wahrscheinlich auch selbst machen aber
wir müssen noch mal ein community
kräftigen table aufstellen
das ist auf jeden fall so patrick ich
hoffe dass ich darin so community wisst
ihr wisst ja wieder geilo lifestyle
gelebt wird der gottverdammte gaildorfs
werk wird gespritzt durch den klub wie
du mir leid dass ich leute verstört habe
so hoch da und ein allerletztes mal blut
opfern und jetzt checken wie viel drin
ist 5400 das heißt wir können den
android noch rein dollar und wenn man es
beim nächsten mal einloggen haben wir
den prentis blatt in der hand mit denen
wir uns dann ja möglichst zwei die neiße
sache machen können oder ich würde mal
wie schnell das geht
es geht schon relativ flott glaub ich
warte das bisschen einfach noch ab ja
das ist das geht schnell ja ich will es
jetzt mal machen also dann gehe ich
vielleicht eine minute oder 2 aber es
wäre auf jeden fall mégane eis zu
nächste folge zweifelsohne essen gibt es
gar keine alternativen ist muss was
gemacht werden
in puncto essen sonst bin ich echt am
arsch so wie viel drin
ok gleiches er fertig der prentice
plattform und dann können wir den hier
glaube ich schon in die tonne kloppen
weil wir es dann geschafft haben und den
nächsten crash blatt haben und hier ist
er heute damit beende ich die folge das
war's von heute bis zum nächsten mal und
tschüss